We are now going to discuss this issue
of a new world order. As we saw in
Revelation chapter 17, the kings of the
world give their power unto the beast.
In the keys of this blood, Malachi
Martin
tells us that the greatest geopolitical
giant of our age is the pope.
He says on his trip to Poland, barely
eight months after his election, he
signaled the opening of the millennium
end game. He became the first of three
players to enter the new geopolitical
arena. He says that Pope John Paul would
stride on now in the arena of this
endgame as something more than a
geopolitical giant of his age. He was
and remains the serene and confident
servant of the grand design. This is
Masonic signal language. Here is John
Paul 2 with the trilateral commission.
And here is John Paul 2 with Benit
Jewish Freemasonry.
This is a fascinating signal picture
with him in the center controlling the
most powerful think tanks in the world
because that's what the signal tells us.
We saw in Revelation chapter 17 already
some pictures of the powers of the world
giving themselves over to the papacy.
Leza being honored for his work with the
host in public.
The Bush Gorbachov summit in Malta,
George Bush referred to as a gateway to
the millennium of freedom and it was
heralded as the building of a new world.
It is a big idea new world order where
diverse nations are drawn together in
common cause. Only the United States has
both the moral standing and the means to
back it up. So they want to create this
new world order. Revelation chapter 13
said that the beast that comes up out of
the earth would be the power that did
it. Bush confirms that for us.
By 1990, a peace prize went to Gorbachof
for losing his country. A man of the
decade he became. And the old symbols
which are Masonic symbols of the East
German Empire were removed. The
communist emblem leaves.
Pritoria News August 20, 1999.
Uh summit meeting with 63 in 63
countries about neoliberalism
and Fedel Castro gives a masonic signal.
Here he is with the papacy. All these
so-called countries that are against
what the establishment stands for are
only against in the sense that they are
playing the game of Hegelianism
thesis anti-thesis but behind the scenes
they all belong to the same club let's
just verify that Fiddle was
significantly influenced by Jesuit
father Amando Lorento and Alberto
Dcastro
uh Dcastro admired Frank Fiddle was very
active in a Jesuit organization similar
to the Boy Scouts, the Explorers.
Wherever totalitarian
movement erupts, whether communist or
Nazi, a Jesuit can be found in the role
of advisor or leader. In Cuba, it was
Castro's father, Amando Lorente. So,
forget about the idea that Cuba was
antipope. A Jesuit was behind the
scenes. is they were playing the game of
thesis anti-thesis.
When tyrants fall in Romania and Panama
and all these countries, these tyrants
were put in place to create a system of
fear and chaos and then they are removed
and the people are happy to give up
their civil liberties. We've already
seen this video here of the Pope who
receives honor from Bill Clinton for his
uh role in ending the communist empire.
>> 2400 of his faithful here to welcome
him.
He's waving to the crowd.
Archbishop Regali is alongside the Pope
as he shakes hands with the first lady.
We honor you for helping to lead a
revolution of values and spirit in
Central Europe and the former Soviet
Union, freeing millions to live by
conscience, not coercion, and freeing
all of us from the constant fear of
nuclear war.
Your holiness, on behalf of all of us
gathered here today, indeed on behalf of
all the people of our beloved nation, we
welcome you back to America.
Ladies and gentlemen, his holiness Pope
John Paul II
and
the Vice President of the United States
and Archbishop
>> Pope declares the European Community
Heavenscent.
Very fascinating. Conrad Ardinawa who
was the German chancellor at that
particular time when this was being
devised. Well, he is to be declared a
saint. Can you believe that? He is to be
declared a saint for his work. Pope
declares EU heaven saints and saints at
the moment Roman Catholic principles
they are to be declared saints. Now to
bring about the European Union they had
Marsh. Marsh is a Roman Catholic little
town in a Protestant country in the
Netherlands. And the symbolism there was
very interesting. The 12 stars they
represent also the 12 stars that you
have in the book of Revelation which
they apply to Mary rather than to the
woman in white.
It is also fascinating that the European
Union issued a poster which was posted
all over Europe where they had the tower
of babel under construction. Can you see
that this was posted all over Europe and
the stars were upside down representing
the goat of mendus. This is Satanism.
This is the new tower of babel. And uh
the high French politicians said we are
building a new Babel which they
emphasized with this poster and this
time we will succeed. The new parliament
of the European community is built like
the Tower of Babel. In fact, it has a
plaque on the inside or a poster which
says precisely this. And it has these
scaffolding to give the appearance that
it is under construction. This is rather
arrogant. This is the new European
identity card. And if you look at it at
the back and you turn it upside down,
what do you see? You see the goat of
Mendes. The horns are slightly modified
to give another symbolism of the seat of
the earth. But uh the inner facial
features of the goat are very clearly
discernible. And what these mean over
here, I would rather not say.
If we look at the high politicians of
Europe, those that played the role in
all of this, they are Masonic. That is a
masonic handshake between Shredder and
Call signifying the new Mason is taking
over where the old Mason is leaving. So
just as we saw that uh Kerry is a Skull
and Bones member in America now and the
present president is a Skull and Bones
member. It doesn't member matter which
one is going to win. So here too Mason
replaces Mason
fingering the system. They're all
showing that they are all part of the
same system. When the Soviet Union fell,
the new emblem that it adopted was this
one, the double-headed eagle. Could you
guess why?
Well, the double-headed eagle is the
symbol of Freemasonry.
And it obviously shows who is in
control. The queens, the kings of the
world as we have seen all of them are
highmasons and subject to the Roman
pontiff and Islam. We did a whole
lecture to show the intrigue of the
Islamic religion and the Catholic
religion that behind the scenes
controlled by the secret societies
they have one aim and one aim alone
subject to Rome. So what is all this war
about with Islam? Who are these people
who are pulling the strings in the
world? And why are people being rubbed
up between them? From the rock stars of
the world, the bonos of the world to the
political leaders of the world, everyone
seems to be bowing down to the papal
Caesar. from the east to the west. The
Islamic world is currently being set up
as the synthesis in the religious world
pitted against the Judea Christian
culture as the anti-thesis and then out
of this must come a synthesis where all
of them will unite. This is a website.
There is the the actual website
underneath. And this one I believe
fairly accurately says who's who in the
zoo. Adam Vice, Aster Pike, Cariegi,
Deont, Harman, Bertrren Russell, Ted
Kennedy. These are the Illuminatis
uh of yesterday year and today. George
W. Bush, of course, he's a Skull and
Bones member. That's a suborganization
of chapter 322 of a German organization.
The Illuminati therefore Bundy,
Hapsburg, Freeman, Tenhoi, Hillary
Clinton, Alan Greenspan,
Rockefeller, Rosschild, Wahberg. These
are the bankers in the system. The
negotiators
Lord Carrington, Jimmy Carter, Henry
Kissinger, Lord David Owen, Richard
Hullbrook. These are 33 frem degree
Freemasons or Knights of Malta or
Bilderberers committee of 300 they all
belong to the same club.
If we look at uh Franklin, Rouserfeld,
Ceil Roads, Engles, all of these Trosky,
Stalin, Marx, Hoover, all of their
affiliations, Grand Orient Lodge for
example, Grand Orient Lodge, u Lenon was
Grand Orient Lodge, Truman 33 degree,
Villy Brunt 33°ree, Winston Churchill.
We've seen many of these before. for
helmet call committee of 300. Frantois
Miton 33 degree Freemason he does he's
not alive anymore yasa Arafat 33 degree
Freemason these are fascinating details
Shimon Perez Ronald Reagan George Bush
Gerald Ford I showed you Gerald Ford's
signature where he signed for himself
that he was a 33 degree Freemason there
it is I photographed it in the lodge and
the Carters and these great political
people in the world The Schwasers, the
Netanyahus, the Gorbachovs. There is
Saddam Hussein listed as a 33 degree
Freemason.
Now, that is somewhat strange, wouldn't
you say? King Hussein, Al Gore, Tony
Blair, all of these issues. Look at
Saddam Hussein over there. Here's a
picture of Saddam Hussein. And this is a
picture that was beamed on national
television during the war. during the
war of what he looked like. Now, they
also said at that stage that they
weren't sure whether this was pre-taped.
That means it could have been pre-taped
before the war even took place because
if they are insiders, they would know
who's who and what is going to happen.
Now, there is a very interesting rumor
about this man. Have a look at his face
and have a look at the fact that he has
no beard. The CIA as well as the British
Secret Service said at the time it could
be a double. It could be a double. But
nevertheless, that is what was depicted.
He has always looked like this. He's
never had a beard. This is what he's
looked like. Operation Iraqi Freedom.
Saddam's double trouble. Opposition
leader claims Hussein died of cancer in
99. This was posted March 26, 2003.
Muslim al Assadi, a doctor living in
exile in Iran, said he believes the real
Saddam died in 1999 from cancer. The
real Saddam died because he had cancer
of the lymph nodes and since his death
in 1999, they're just showing his
doubles, he told the Tand newspaper.
That's a a fascinating story. If Saddam
Hussein was really dead and the others
were pre-recorded stories, then who was
ruling in his place? his sons and his
wife and his other children were also
there. It fascinated me that the moment
the war broke out and England and the
United States went in there that uh the
wife and the children of Saddam Hussein
except the two ruling sons were taken
away and received exile where? But in
Great Britain. So the country that
attacks takes the family the whole
family of Saddam and gives them uh
political exile in
Great Britain. Very strange.
Now if he was dead and they were putting
doubles in front and they were ruling
really through the suns and they showed
these shot up bodies of two individuals
who nobody knows who they really are.
Who knows whether that is really so or
whether that is not so. despite the
reference to Um Kquaza, British
intelligence thought the broadcast may
have been pre-recorded. This is a fact.
We are well aware that he spent many
hours recently tape recording various
messages. We have to do a little more
analysis of what he was actually saying
to see whether or not that in fact was
Saddam Hussein. British Defense Minister
Joff Jeff Hoon told reporters. White
House spokesman Arif Lasha said, "I
think there are some doubts about
whether that tape is canned or whether
it's fresh and based on recent events."
So both of the secret services question
these issues. Then they find finally
Saddam Hussein's hideout, a filthy place
they say, and they arrest the man and
show him on national television. After
that, one does not hear too much. And he
has a magnificent beard. A magnificent
beard. Now, if the previous one was shot
during the war, then this must be the
best hair fertilizer that mankind has
ever
found. Maybe he could become a
multi-illionaire patenting this
fertilizer to make this beard grow as it
is. They used at least three doubles.
Who knows who this man is? And to say
that they did blood tests, who knows
whether you can trust the laboratories
that did this? Nevertheless, he's listed
as a 33 degree Freemason. There is there
are plenty of questions regarding this
man and uh there is no evidence except
for his family that he's safely living
in exile. royalty. Prince Bernard of the
Netherlands is 300 uh committee of 300.
And here
Prince Beatatric and uh Prince Bertium
the Queen of course, Prince Phillip, all
of them high Freemasons, Mangala, Walt
Disney, all of these individuals. The
world is really run by these
individuals. Here is the Duke of Kent
giving the Masonic handshake under the
Masonic shield. He is the current
grandmaster.
So he is the highest freemason at the
moment if you like because a king may
not be or a prince may not be the
grandmaster. He is currently the
grandmaster. So here is the highest
luciferium in the country at the moment.
political leaders, the Bill Clintons and
all of these. We've dealt with them. Uh
we don't have to go through all of them
again. The Jesse Helms, the Goldwaters,
the Al Gors, and all of these
individuals. And I've put the the pages
up there and there are many, many books
that substantiate all of these names. So
just about everybody who is important in
the world, everybody who runs in the
political sphere is involved in these
clandestine operations. We saw in the
lecture on Revelation chapter 17 and 13
how there would be a holy alliance and
how the United States would eventually
become the powerhouse for propagating a
new world order. Gorbachev summit in
Malta referred to as the gateway to the
millennium of freedom as you will
remember and the initiative came for
this great movement into a new world
order. Now let us have a look at this
video where George Bush has something to
say on this issue.
For institutions of freedom have lain
dormant. The United Nations can offer
them new life. These institutions
play a crucial role in our quest for a
new world order. An order in which no
nation must surrender one iota of its
own sovereignty. An order characterized
by the rule of law
rather than the resort to force.
So he says all the nations don't have to
give up one iota of their sovereignty
but we want them all in a new world
order. Basically that is what he said
out of the horse's mouth.
And then this terrible incident took
place
and
well there were many many deaths. a very
strange incident.
But before we get to it, let's first
have the have a look at some of the
history of this issue. The United States
had a problem in that it wanted to
introduce anti-terrorism laws, but there
was no real terrorism in the United
States. And then all of a sudden a
building in Oklahoma, April 19, 1995,
was gutted by explosions. And they
fingered a man, Timothy McVey, who
worked alone, they said, and brought
this building down by parking a van
filled with explosive outside and
blowing the building to smitherines.
That's the official report.
Inside were women and young children.
And if anything gets the sympathy of the
people, well then that is surely one of
them. Let's have a look at what happened
here
through federal authorities that a
second bomb has been found inside that
federal building in Oklahoma City. It
was an explosion at 9:00 this morning
that did that damage you're looking at
right there.
>> That was in the federal building. did go
off. It did the damage that you see
right there. The second explosive was
found and diffused. The third explosive
that was found and they are working on
right now as we speak. I understand both
the second and third explosives, if you
can imagine this, were larger than the
first first bomb that was in the federal
building did go off. It did the damage
that you see right there.
So you heard there on national
television
that a second bomb went off and it did
the damage that you saw over there. They
found a third explosive device within
the side the building. The official
report, however, says what?
That there was a van outside with
explosives. Now I was not there. I was
not there. So I'm not going to set
myself up as a judge as to what happened
over there. I can merely say what the
report said, what the news said, and
then we'll ask some questions and you
decide what happened over there. Timothy
McVey apparently worked alone just like
in the Kennedy case. They blew this
place up. But eyewitnesses say no, they
saw two individuals and they saw this
truck on a previous day and they had a
number
But when this building exploded, there
was no real crater where this truck is
supposed to have exploded. Now, if a
truck explodes outside the building,
there must be a crater. And the building
must implode. But the building didn't
implode, it exploded. And that was done
by a device on the inside, as you heard
over here.
So now to fit the case and to say it was
a truck, the people said, "Well, surely
if it was a truck, then there must be
some parts left of that truck. I mean,
an explosion doesn't just get rid of
every piece of a truck. It might be in
smithetheriness, but there should be a
piece of an engine block or something
like that. There was nothing."
Eventually, the pressure became so great
that a CIA agent jogging four blocks
away stumbled over the rear axle of the
truck and found it. But the problem was
how do you identify this rear axle as
part of that truck? Now, they had a
registration number and fortunately the
number was on the rear axle.
Nowhere in the whole world do you put
registration numbers of vehicles on rear
axles.
So this is a strange issue
but anyway he was fingered as the sole
one but there is so much suspicion
surrounding this explosion and then
eventually a firm got the contract and
they gutted that building before there
was any possibility of looking into what
happened at that particular event.
Then came another event, the Twin
Towers. Now, what happened after the
first event? After the Oklahoma bombing,
the United States within just 5 days had
anti-terrorism legislation.
And that anti-terrorism legislation gave
powers to the president of the United
States where he could suspend the
Constitution. But it didn't give powers
where the United States could
unilaterally enter any country in the
world to do as it pleased. For that, it
needed a warfooting legislation, as was
the case with Pearl Harbor. There needed
to be an incident. Well, an incident
arrived in that the Twin Towers were
destroyed. President Bush speaks to the
United Nations General Assembly November
10, 2001.
We must speak the truth about terror.
Let us never tolerate outrageous
conspiracy theories
concerning the attacks of September the
11th.
Malicious lies that attempt to shift the
blame away from the terrorists
themselves, away from the guilty.
Now, isn't it interesting that George
Bush there said, "Let us not tolerate
conspiracy theories that shift the blame
away from the terrorists themselves."
Why? Because so many people started
believing that everything was not right
with these particular issues.
Now, let's have a look at the first hit.
When this happened, the first airplane
struck.
Jim, your life is going to change, but
more important, your son's life is going
to change forever. America will never be
the same after September 11th.
>> We've been preparing for this kind of
event for nearly a decade. We've had
presidential directives. It's a project
called Homeland Defense.
>> We are, as we have been saying this
morning, in a
>> So, what we have, we have footage of the
very first airplane striking that
building. That means
there was an opportunity to record that
very quickly. The following happened.
>> Even as the leaders of the Taliban deny
any role in this. An Arab based an Arab
journalist based in London is quoted
today to the Associated Press as saying
that followers of Osama bin Laden warned
three weeks ago they were going to carry
out this sort of an attack. The chief of
safety of the fire department of New
York City told me he received word of
the possibility of a secondary device,
that is another bomb going off. Uh he
tried to get his men out as quickly as
he could, but he said that there was
another explosion which took place and
according to his theory, he thinks that
there were actually devices that were
planted in the building.
>> 45 minutes into the taping that we were
doing, there was an explosion. It was
way up where the fire was and the whole
building at that point bellied out in
flames
and everybody ran.
>> I was about five blocks away when I
heard explosions, three thuds and turn
around to see the building we just got
out of antenna tip over and fall in on
itself.
>> And then all of a sudden it started like
like it sounded like gunfire, you know,
bang bang bang bang bang. And then and
then all of a sudden three big
explosions.
>> All right. So the eyewitnesses said that
they heard secondary devices. Bang bang
bang bang and a series of explosions and
then these buildings came down.
Demolition experts said that this is
exactly what happens in a controlled
demolition. You see, when an airplane
strikes, there was a huge fireball and
the fireball is the burning of all the
fuel on side on board the airplane. So
there was nothing left there to explode.
What was responsible for the secondary
explosions?
If we look at the setup, you will see
there are the twin towers and there are
buildings all around.
And these buildings were either slightly
damaged or not seriously damaged. And
then there is this a road and there's
another building over there called
building number seven. And that building
came down sometime afterwards although
nothing hit it and not much was ever
said about that. What caused building
number seven to implode? Let's watch it.
Okay, now watch close.
>> Hours after the first plane crash, a
third building at the World Trade Center
collapses. This one, the number seven
World Trade Center building.
>> This is a look at the flying debris from
the number seven tower. You're going to
see that coming down this way toward the
camera. Number seven tower at the World
Trade Center. The CIA would have been in
there normally, but they had of course
abandoned the building uh when the uh
event of catastrophe occurred.
>> So who would have been in that building?
>> The CIA would have been in that
building, but they had evacuated the
building and 8 hours afterwards the
building comes down in a controlled it
seems implosion.
Now nothing hit that building and these
are very strange strange questions that
we have to consider. After this event
there was a Canadian response
>> and there was a great resolution passed
at the United Nation last night that
might bring about a new order in the
world that would be better for all of
us. All of this was brought upon us in a
single day
and nightfell on a different world.
A world where freedom itself is under
attack.
>> So the Canadian response was this could
bring about a new order in the world as
it was decided at the United Nations
after a meeting. Gary Hart, what did he
have to say?
There is a chance for the president of
the United States to use this disaster
to carry out what his father a phrase
his father used I think only once and
hasn't been used since and that is a new
world order.
>> Jim your life is going to change but
more important your son's life is going
to change forever. America will never be
the same after September 11th.
>> We've been preparing for this kind of
event for nearly a decade. We've had
presidential directives. It's a project
called homeland defense.
>> We are, as we have been saying this
morning, in a state of war.
>> Even as the leaders of the Taliban deny
any role in this, an Arab based an Arab
journalist based in London is quoted
today to the Associated Press as saying
that followers of Osama bin Laden warned
three weeks ago they were going to carry
out this sort of an attack.
>> The chief of safety of the fire
department of New York City told me he
received word of the possibility of a
secondary device. That is another bomb
going off. Uh he tried to get his men
out as quickly as he could, but he said
that there was another explosion which
>> All right, that's enough.
We've seen the buildings coming down.
We've heard that while these things were
still happening, the American government
had fingered the culprits. a bunch of
terrorists main naming their names about
25 of them altogether and the whole plot
had been resolved by the end of the
events that unfolded that day. An
amazing piece of detective work after
the event while it was even happening.
Now again let me say I was not there. So
let me tell you what has transpired and
what people have said about these issues
in the world. What has been published
and what is fact that cannot be disputed
and then I don't make a judgment because
I wasn't there. You make the judgment
based on the facts.
This is the story. They say the
terrorists were of Arab extraction and
they mentioned the names of the
passengers on these airplanes which were
United Airline airplanes.
And the mastermind behind the scene is a
man by the name of Ata who is fingered
as the one who received instruction on
how to fly an airplane. Well, when they
released the names, immediately there
was a human cry from the Arab countries
because five of the terrorists, supposed
terrorists, mentioned that they were
very much alive and well and couldn't
have been on the plane.
Right? Very important. They were alive
and well and couldn't have been on the
plane. How did they know that Ata was
the mastermind? You see on his way to
the airport he had just happened to
leave his documents in the taxi that was
transporting him. So they had his
documentation. Which terrorist would
leave his documentation behind? That is
the one question. The next point that is
very interesting is that they have
evidence that he was the man because he
wrote a suicide note. This is all fact.
This is all published fact. What I'm
saying now, I'm not making this up. This
is all reference. This is this is a
fact. You decide the rest for yourself.
Now, he wrote a suicide note.
And this suicide note he then placed
within his suitcase.
And then he handed in the suitcase as we
normally do when we go onto the
airplane. Now, which person would write
a suicide note that was going to be
destroyed in an airplane clash? Does
that make any sense? So, the fact of the
matter is they have a suicide note. But
now the question is if you handed in his
suitcase to be put on top inside the
plane, how come they have the suicide
note? Well, just by chance, this is the
one suitcase they forgot to put on the
plane.
And that is how they have his notes. How
do they know there were Arab terrorists
in there? Because a passport, nothing
else survived that plane crash, but a
passport fell out and it happened to be
a burntout passport which still could
identify one of the terrorists.
This is very circumstantial.
Now, as these airplanes with absolute
precision struck those twin towers,
their black boxes were totally
obliterated. These are of titanium and
are designed to survive such crashes.
There is no evidence of them whatsoever.
They have been totally destroyed.
So, we have a very strange situation.
What he hit building number seven?
Nothing hit it, but it came down in like
fashion. And there is plenty of evidence
that uh there were possibly secondary
devices in the buildings as you heard
from the commentators themselves.
So
what about the infrastructure of the
airplanes? Well, there are certain parts
lying there. So there was definitely a
situation where those planes hit that
particular
building because you have wheels and all
kinds of components of the airplanes
surviving. Even those crashes with those
tremendous explosions, there were parts
of these aircrafts everywhere. Every
time an airplane crashes, there are huge
pieces of fuselage and etc. which remain
and they sometimes can fit all these
things together. And that was also the
case at the Twin Towers. 3 days before
those buildings came down, 3 days before
the shares in the airlines had been sold
at a turnover such as had not existed
ever before and certain banks bought
these. So somebody might have been
tipped off that something was going on.
And then a very interesting case. There
was a man in your country in Canada who
happened to be in prison
and they had caught him in a gambling
situation and they imprisoned him and he
said let me go. I am cleansersteinly
working for the CIA. I'm an agent. I was
investigating money laundering etc etc
etc. and they would not let him go. Then
he gave the names of his contacts at the
CIA and the CIA was probably embarrassed
because of this situation and denied
knowledge of it and he was very angry
because he felt he had been stabbed in
the back
and this very often happens in this
industry. And so he wrote a letter
before the September 11 attack outlining
some events that were going to take
place. and he mentioned that aircraft
were going to fly into the twin towers
and into the Pentagon. Now, nobody made
any use of these, but when it actually
happened, then this came to the four.
So, here was a CIA agent who said ahead
of time that this was going to happen.
Could be chance, could not be chance.
You decide for yourself. a certain utter
the man who is supposed to have planned
this with only inflight training with
absolute precision they went into those
buildings
this is an amazing story received funds
$100,000 US
from Pakistan secret societ
secret service into his bank accounts
and they worked very closely with the
United States so here had been a
transfer of money. But the plot doesn't
end there.
Daspers says it's them Pentagon facts.
The evil sits in the Pentagon. Now, who
is this man that wrote this? This is uh
the political scientist Tiier Mess from
France and uh he has something very
interesting to say. Who was it? What
happened over here? How come they had
all the names of all these people and
yet there is no real evidence that these
people were actually on board?
Uh here's the story. I'm just giving it
to you with the passengers
machines that flew into these twin
towers. And then there's this
fascinating case of the other airplane
that went into the Pentagon. And here
are the pictures that were published.
The dates were strangely wrong. They
were September 12th, but apparently they
said is because they released them the
next day. And what you see is smoke over
there. There are no debris pots,
nothing. Here is a piece missing. No
picture. There you have an impact of uh
a flame and you have this fireball over
here. That's it.
If you look then on the lawn, this is
all that was found. But no part of a
United N uh Airlines aircraft. No parts.
Nothing. Nothing whatsoever. This is the
hole that was seen after the event. And
most of this hole happened well after
the event. So the question is why are
there no aircraft pots? Again, all the
black boxes disappear. There were no
black boxes that survive and the hole is
way too small for something like that to
actually have happened because nowhere
in the world even in the locker disaster
there was a case where there were no
aircraft parts nothing. There was just
nothing.
What is even more interest interesting
in this situation
is when you look at this when the United
States rules the world the Catholic
Church will rule the world. Archbishop
Quigley 1903.
Let me go back to this September 11. To
rule the world, you have to be able to
have access to the entire world whenever
you want to, however you want to. Now,
this airplane that struck the Pentagon
and the other one that fell by chance.
Did you know about that? The other one
that fell and apparently there were
terrorists on board that were overcome
by loyal citizens. The interesting part
is that that airplane struck the ground
and never struck any building. It came
down and as it came down, there was a
hole in the ground.
And the mayor and the first people of
that area ran to the place and here was
a hole in the ground but no aircraft
debris. None. None whatoever.
Not the slightest piece. Nothing.
So the whole aircraft disappeared into a
hole
which was not very large and there was
no debris and no black boxes and
nothing. Something like this has never
ever happened ever before.
But what is even more sinister is the
following.
Because the people that had died on the
airplane,
their descendants or their inheritors
cannot claim if there is no body.
But in the investigation,
they identified every single human body
with their blood group and body parts
that were given to all the family.
There were no aircraft parts. There was
nothing of that nature found. No
airplane whatsoever.
And yet they could identify everybody.
Does that make any sense? It doesn't
make any sense whatsoever.
And there were apparently phone calls
between the aircraft and the Pentagon.
Such was the information that was
released. And the information was that
there was a terrorist group, Arab
terrorists that were attacking this
place.
And the phone call was made with a handy
with a cell phone.
But then of course they found out that
if you make a phone call with a cell
phone then you get an account for that
phone call and there was no record of
such a phone call. So the Pentagon
backtracked one and said yes excuse me
we didn't actually
uh make get the phone call from a cell
phone. We got it from the onboard
telephone. That's how it happened.
Again, they did an investigation. If you
make a telephone call on an onboard
phone, then you swipe your credit card
through it and there must be a record of
a credit card transaction from that
phone. But there was no record.
So the Pentagon backtracked again and
said, "Yes, that is true, but it was
done as a collect call.
That's why there was no credit card
because the individual had forgotten the
credit card. But you cannot make a
collect call from an onboard telephone.
And there the story died.
So here are four aircraft,
no parts except the ones at the Twin
Towers.
There are
holes in the ground and no aircraft
whatsoever,
but all the pieces of the bodies with
the DNA analysis. These are interesting,
very interesting facts.
They had planned previously in the Bay
of Pigs one such operation apparently.
This is history where they were going to
dupe
the world by having one aircraft take
off, land, the people get out and then
another one radio control take off and
create the situation that they wanted
without any people on board. This had
been done before in the United States.
So ask yourself the following questions.
How is it possible that all this
circumstantial evidence points to
nobody out there? Nobody out there. Then
came anthrax scares and when eventually
someone high up in politics suggested
that uh it seems to come from a
laboratory within suddenly there was
absolute silence. So let us not continue
with the September 11 and ask and say it
was this or that party. The fact of the
matter is this is a very strange
situation.
And if you look at the high role players
in the United States, whether it's
Marilyn Albbright or any one of them,
they use broches which depict Luciferian
connections like goats and all of these.
President Clinton here is receiving the
host publicly
and he claims not to be a Roman
Catholic. That is impossible. Hillary
Clinton is wearing the Fernick's rising
which is a Masonic symbol. Uh Sher Blair
uses Masonic signals. The presidents,
the prime ministers of the world,
whether the Thatchers or the Carters or
the whoever they are, all of them seem
to belong to insider organizations,
whether they are religious leaders or
political leaders or whether they are
Europeans or Americans or Eastern all of
them seem to be involved.
So before we continue uh let us first
contemplate what happens in the Africa
situation but we'll do that in another
session.
If we look at Africa and Rome, this will
give us an idea of what the new world
order is going to be all about. Africa
and what they have done to Africa serves
as a model for what will happen in the
entire world. The great African leaders
and the the tyrants of the past like the
idi
have all received exile and were
probably high masonics. When we look at
the southern Africa, South Africa
situation where you had the black white
issue, the apartheite issue, the role
players again were all Masons. This is
Foster
the president and he gives a masonic
signal and he was a Freemason. If we
look at Nelson Mandela, he is a Prince
Hall Freemason. So again both sides are
on the same side of a secret society. If
we look at um declar and Nelson Mandela
we have the same situation there.
Mandela is compared to Jesus Christ.
They lift him up. They have a synthesis
and an anthesis and he receives the host
publicly although he declines to say
that he is Roman Catholic. He says he's
not Roman Catholic. Now Roman Catholic
cannon law states that you cannot
receive the host if you are not a Roman
Catholic. So these people are really
something else. Here he has a Hindu uh
marriage with the widow of Samura
Marshal.
Now Samura Marshal is another story and
uh his anti-Christian statements are
historic.
He also had a uh Jewish wedding at the
same ceremony and a Muslim showing that
all religions are one with him. The new
political face is totally Masonic. And
in 1992 already it was known that Muggab
of Zimbabwe was going to take the farms
away from the people that lived there.
This is before he started doing this.
They had already said it. Muggab is
going to take white farms very soon. It
was in 1992.
Today, this is a fact. Despel published
the Deutsch Men. The Germans must get
out. All whites must get out. Here's a
cartoon of Kissinger pointing to the
fact that the whites must get out of
Africa. Here is the current president of
South Africa, MKI and Mugab. They are
hand in hand on this issue. He refuses
to rebuke Mugab for taking the farms by
force. In South Africa itself, 4,000
farmers at least have died and have been
killed as they have been driven off
their land. Nobody hears about these
things in the world. Zimbabwe lies in
ruins. But what do we find here? A
tremendous building going up. And what
is it called? The Jesuit province of
Zimbabwe. So the Jesuits are totally in
control in that country. Jesuit school
of philosophy and the humanities. Brand
new buildings while a country lies in
ruins. They're preparing for a final
order.
And all the black leaders are in the
same level as all the European and
American leaders. They all belong to the
same club. Now what is this new world
order? Here is the new South African
coat of arms where you can see the
fernics rising out of the ashes, the
crown of Mitra with a with the seven
rays. All the symbolism points to the
same thing. I'm going to run you through
the new economic order of the new world
order. And these are now quotes from
Roman Catholic sources themselves. And I
would like to tell you that you haven't
experienced anything yet, waiting to
come to you. And I can tell you what it
feels like because I've experienced it.
If you ever want to read an interesting
book, read ecclesiastical megalomania.
But I'll be quoting from encyclicals and
all these things. According to canon
law, the control of all property of the
Roman church state belongs to the pope,
its supreme emperor.
Everything I say will have a quote. Now
everything is substantiated
by either papal encyclical or any one of
these. Now communism took all property
away and made it the state's property.
Capitalism says the property belongs to
the individual and nobody has the right
to take it away. Now if that is thesis
and anti-thesis then something in
between is what we will want. So the
pope condemned communism but he also
condemns capitalism. The new world order
will be something in between in the name
of fairness.
So let us have a look at these issues.
the economic thought of the Roman
Catholic Church, private property.
Thomas Aenus wrote no treatise on
economics, but he's thinking based on
that of the of Aristotle is foundational
for understanding the economic thought
of the Roman Catholic Church. Every time
there is a quote now, what did Thomas
Ainus say? Roman Catholic economic
thought is develop as developed by the
popes in their encyclicals and by the
Roman church state councils has been a
contributor to one feudalism guild
socialism in Europe during the middle
ages fascism in Italy, Spain, Portugal,
Nazism in Germany in the 20th century,
interventionism and redistributive state
in the west including the United States
in the 20th century and liberation
theology in Latin America and Africa in
the 20th century.
What does this mean? Thomas Ainus said,
"The possession of all things in common
is natural law." Thomas wrote, "The
possession of all things in common and
use of universal freedom are said to be
of the natural law because to the
distinction of possessions and slavery
were not brought in by nature, but
devised by human reason for the benefit
of human life." Now, what does all that
mean? It simply means property is for
common good. You may own it, but it is
for common good. The community of goods,
wrote Thomas, is ascribed to natural
law, not that the natural law dictates
that all things should be possessed in
common, and that nothing should be
possessed as one own's own. So you may
possess things, yes, but because the
division of possessions is not according
to natural law, but rather arose from
human agreement, which belongs to
positive law. They talk such dil. It's
interesting. Never mind. Hence the
ownership of possessions is not contrary
to natural law but an addition thereto
devised by human reason. Let's continue.
Thomas wrote, "Hence, whatever certain
people have in super abundance is due by
natural law to the purpose of suckering
the poor." Okay, now we're getting
there.
You may possess things, whatever you
possess, but whatever you possess more
than you need is there for the common
good of those that don't have. Does that
make sense? Now, what if you create two
classes of individuals, the rich and the
poor? Or what if there is a situation
where you have two classes, the rich and
the poor? You can go across the world
and you can look at the rich nations and
the poor nations and you will find that
the rich nations are all the Protestant
nations. Have you noticed that all the
Protestant nations are the rich? Now
what if you had a plan to disinherit
them all
so that you would again be ruler and
they would have to come and beg at your
feet for anything like that. Now let's
have a look at this how this uh unfolds.
For the purpose of suckering the poor
because the goods of some are due to
others by natural law, there is no sin
if the poor take the goods of their
neighbors.
Thomas wrote, "In cases of need, all
things are common property, so that
there would seem to be no sin in taking
another's properties, for the need has
made it common.
Okay. Now, there's the aspect of
sharing. If I see my neighbor in trouble
as a good Christian, I will help him
out. Right? Yes. But now we're looking
at law. So, if my neighbor has need, and
who determines the need? He He
determines the need. I have need. I have
a need. I have a need of a television.
And I don't have one. And you have one.
And you have money. And you can go and
buy yourself another one. I have need of
your television. Can he then take it
without being a sinner? Yes or no?
According to this, yes. What if you have
a car and he doesn't have one?
He can take it without sin. According to
Thomas Ainus, now this was a long time
ago. Surely this doesn't apply today.
Well, we'll see. Not only is such taking
of another's property not a sin, it is
not even a crime. According to Thomas,
it is lawful for a man to sucker his own
need by means of another's property by
taking it either openly or secretly.
Nor is this properly speaking theft and
robbery. It is not theft properly
speaking to take secretly and use
another's property in a case of extreme
need because that which he takes for the
support of his life becomes his own
property by reason of that need. In a
case of a like need, a man may also take
secretly another's property in order to
sucker his neighbor in need. Oh, this
gets very interesting.
Now, did you know that if I leave my
property unattended in South Africa
and somebody moves in, I cannot throw
him out? He's in because he has need.
That's the law. And you think that is a
South African law? No, that is a British
law as well. That is a law virtually all
over the country now, but it's not being
implemented because the situation is not
such yet that it has to be implemented
everywhere. Once you start opening the
borders and millions of poor people
start coming in, well then there will be
great need.
What did they do with need overseas?
So in South Africa, people go on
holiday, they come back, their house is
occupied
and they can't throw the piece people
out because their property is in their
name. They have to pay the bills. They
have to pay the rates. They have to pay
all those things. But need made it
common. Therefore, that man can move in.
Is that the situation? Yes, it is. Gets
worse. The Roman Catholic doctrine of
private property is echoed in the 19th
century communist slogan from each
according to his ability to each
according to his need. Can you see the
Roman Catholic doctrine there? Human
rights are more important than property
rights. It was the creed of Lynon
Johnson's great society. We shall take
from the halves and give to the have
nots who need it so much.
Lynon Johnson said that. What continent
is that?
It appears in the literature of fascism,
Nazism, liberation theology,
interventionism and socialism,
the universal destination of goods. This
is John Paul 2's expression of it in
1987 in an encyclical site called on
social concern. It is necessary to state
once more the characteristic principle
of Christian social doctrine. The goods
of this world are originally meant for
all. The right of private property is
valid and necessary but it does not
nullify the value of this principle.
Private property in fact is under a
social mortgage which means that it has
an intrinsically social function based
upon the justified precisely by the
principle of universal destination of
goods. Oops. What did John Paul 2 just
say? He said that which Thomas said is
what I say. You may have private
property. The Roman Catholic Church is
for private property. That sounds very
nice,
but it's never qualified that that
property is only yours for common good.
So one day you wake up and in your
garden you have squatters
and you call the police and you say,
"Hey." Or you go out and you say, "Get
off my property." And they say, "Let me
alone or I'll blow your head off." Hey,
you go to the cops. You say, "Cops, come
help here. People squatting on my land.
Sorry, they have need. You have too much
land anyway. Live with it."
Okay.
But Paul V 6 made the point quite clear
in 1967 in cyclical on the progress of
people. Each man has therefore the right
to find in the world what is necessary
for himself. This gets interesting. The
recent council Vatican 2 reminded us of
this. God intended the earth and all
that it contains for the use of every
human being and people. Thus, as all men
follow justice and unite in charity,
created goods, created goods should
abound for them on a reasonable basis.
All other rights whatsoever, including
those of property and of free commerce,
are to be subordinate to this principle.
That means if I have need of a
manufactured good, can I take it? So now
I'm driving my car and we have a
hijacking just about every 12 minutes
and a gun comes in and says, "Get out of
the car." And I relinquish my car and if
I don't, what happens to me? I get shot.
The man has need of my car. It's gone.
Finished.
In my own church at home, we've had
hijackings after hijackings. Even the
pastor, they beat him up and tried to
put him into the trunk of the car. They
would have killed him. He managed to
fight himself free and off he went
without his car.
Do you think there's any big action to
find these things? No. Occasionally here
and occasionally there. Do you think
there's any big action when the farmers
are killed and they move onto the lands?
No. A little bit here and a little bit
there just to keep people happy. But
basically nothing is done. and the
police hands are cut off. The law says
that there's nothing you can do. The
other day,
two cyclists were traveling along when
they were hijacked by five gunmen
demanding their bikes.
So, they took out, they were armed
because they expect this. It's becoming
like the wild west. And they defended
themselves, injured one, and got away.
And guess what? The two cyclists are in
jail.
Yes. Serving a sentence for injuring
someone without need. They could have
given them the bicycles. That would have
solved the problem.
You see how the law has turned upside
down. Gandom best the Vatican 2
constitution. Pope Paul quoted explains
at greater length. If one is in extreme
necessity, he has the right to procure
for himself what he needs out of the
riches of others.
Now who defines necessity?
Since there are so many people prostrate
with hunger in the world, the sacred
council urges all both individuals and
governments to remember the aforism of
the fathers. Feed the man dying of
hunger because if you have not fed him,
you have killed him. Therefore, because
private property is immoral, all men,
individuals, and governments have the
moral obligation to redistribute goods
held unjustly by property owners. Have
you heard of redistribution of goods
lately? Have you heard of it many times
lately? Yes, there is going to be a
redistribution. All goods includes not
just goods found in nature but
manufactured goods as well. John Paul 2
declared that all men must have access
to those goods. Quote, which are
intended for common use, both the goods
of nature and manufactured goods. I own
nothing. Only on paper do I own every
anything. The state rules supreme. My
life soon could be a misery. So if you
are attached to your homes here in
Canada and this is the basis for the new
world order. If you are in touch to your
cars and your televisions and all these
things, loosen yourself
because soon they will be redistributed
and there will be nothing that the white
or black or pink Protestant can do about
it. And if some other suffers in the way
that is fair enough, the ends justifies
the means. The redistribution will go as
it should be.
Who's heard of Rum Novarum? This is the
papal encyclical
that was issued that is being quoted to
this day. Pope John's and uh to this day
all of them make reference to this
including Pope John Paul 2 says this is
this encyclical that forms the basis of
the new world order. Well, I thought
it's important to study it. One of the
Roman church church state's most
influential statements on economic
matters is the encyclical rum Novarum on
the condition of the working classes.
The Roman church state all herself with
a proletariat which in Marxism is the
great and final enemy of the capitalist
order. Pious writing declared that rum
Novarum however stood out in this that
it laid down for all mankind unairring
rules for the right solution of
difficult problems of human solidarity
called the social question.
Now let's see by far the most notable
evidence of the social teaching and
action which the church has set forth
through the centuries undoubtedly is the
encyclical Rum Novarum issued 70 years
ago. The norms and recommendations
contained therein was so momentous that
their memory will never fall into
oblivion. John Martistra
the papacy speaking. Pope Pius told us
that the encyclical rumarum was
instrumental in ending less capitalism
in the 20th century by ushering in an
era of effective interference by the
government. Have you got this? Let's see
how it ends up. Navarum was the voice of
moral authority needed to ensure the
development of effective interference by
all governments in the 20th century. How
many governments? All pious wrote, "It
is not surprising, therefore, that under
the teaching and guidance of the church,
many learned priests and layman
earnestly devoted themselves to problems
of elaborating social and economic
science in according with the condition
of our age. Under the guidance and light
of Leo's encyclical Ram Navarum was thus
involved a truly Christian social
science which continues to be fostered
and enriched daily tireless labors all
these people labors. Now note carefully
of those picked men whom we have named
the auxiliaries of the church.
So everybody working in the secret
societies, the Opus died, the this the
might of Malta, the Knights of Columbus,
all of these people working, those
picked men to bring this about, nor were
there the only blessings which followed
from the encyclical. The doctrine of
nerum rovarum began little by little to
penetrate amongst those who being
outside Catholic unity do not recognize
the authority of the church. And these
Catholic principles of social sociology
gradually became the part of the
intellectual heritage of the whole human
race.
Where are we going? I'd like to know.
Thus too, we rejoice that the Catholic
truths proclaimed so vigorously by our
illustrious predecessor are advanced and
advocated not merely in non-atholic
books and journals, but frequently in
legislative assemblies and in courts of
justice.
Those
picked men whom we have named the
auxiliaries of the church who have been
instrumental. This is John Robbins
writing. Who are they? Under fascism,
property owners may keep their property
titles and deeds, but the use of their
property is, as Leo wrote, common.
Fascism is a form of socialism that
retains the forms and trappings of
capitalism, but not its substance. This
is basically what it boils down to. When
we speak of reform of institutions, the
state becomes chiefly to mind not as if
universal well-being were to be expected
from its activities. And now what is the
state going to do in all of this? The
experiment with economic freedom, pious
wrote, must end. And economic life must
again be subjected to planning and
government. Who wants to control your
economic life?
government. John Paul 2 wrote in his
solicitudo re socialis on social
concern. It is necessary to state once
more the characteristic principle of
Christian social doctrine. The goods of
this world are meant for all. Private
property is under social mortgage.
These are the things which will be
controlled. He wrote a faithful echo of
the centuries old tradition of the
church regarding the universal purpose
of good in today's world wrote the pope
we are faced with a serious problem of
unequal distribution of the means of
subsistence originally meant for
everybody.
Then came liberation theology and pas
wrote an encyclical on atheistic
communism an age like ours where unusual
misery has resulted. Who created the
misery?
They created it so that they can create
the solution which they want.
So in Africa they elevate a few and
suppress the masses. Then they turn it
around and they create the situation
that they want. They create communism.
They create the chaos. Out of the chaos
they create the social social order
which they want. So the second reign of
terror was supported by the papacy.
Father Camilo Terus who was shot in 1966
declared the Catholic who is not a
revolutionary is living in mortal sin.
Pope John Paul 2 wrote in 1968, "The
church does not hesitate to defend
fearlessly the just and noble cause of
human rights and to support courageous
reforms leading to a better distribution
of goods including earthly goods such as
education, health service, housing and
so forth.
Now we come to human rights. What did we
read about in the French Revolution?
What's going to be the standard of the
world? Human rights. You have a right to
property. You have a right to anything
that you have need of.
We are convinced that the theology of
liberation is not only timely but useful
and necessary.
That's what the pope says, not me. This
is his words directly. John Paul 2
letter to Brazilian bishops. It should
constitute a new stage of the
theological reflection initiated within
the apos apostolic uh tradition. And
then he refers to rerum novarum.
Franklin Roosefeld when he was elected
he made professor Ryan part of his
administration. Now who was he? Ryan
wrote in 1931
the workers have a claim upon industry
for all the means of living from the
time they begin to work until they die.
When industry does not do it directly
then it is the business of government to
enforce it upon industry. See how it
starts.
Right. Now, let's look at some of the
human rights. You have a right to freely
found unions for working people. You
have a right to culture, a right to
immigrate, a right to immigrate, a right
to food, a right to clothing, a right to
rest, a right to medical care, a right
to just wage, a right to life, a right
to safe environment, a right to personal
security of workers, a right to family
life, a right to private property,
highly qualified, of course, a right to
common use of all goods is just
thereafter, so that means nothing. A
right to work, a right to pension, a
right to old age, insurance, a right to
association, a right to security, a
right to integrity, a right to social
services, a right to strike, a right to
choose a state of life freely, a right
to found a family, a right to education,
employment, good reputation, respect,
appropriate information, a right of the
upright, blah blah blah, protection of
privacy, right to rightful freedom, uh,
professional training, quality, right to
adequate healthcare.
It's laborious.
How do you control that?
If you're going to control every aspect
of that, then you must control every
aspect of a person's life, you will not
be able to go to the toilet in future
without making a triple application to
the Vatican.
They're going to control every single
aspect of your lives. That's what
they're going to control. And government
is going to become super huge.
Now, where's the money going to come
from?
>> From you. Now, when the money comes from
you, what then happens to your
wealth?
It gets less and less and less and less.
That means the middle class will
disappear. How many classes under
Catholicism in the middle ages?
>> Two. There was a feudal class, the goyam
and there was the upper class who
controlled everything. Now if we take
employment
in my country employment was running at
almost 50%. In Germany it was running at
point something%.
And then it went up to two, three, five,
10, 20%. Now unemployment is rife in
Europe. Why? Because all the east block
countries are now being incorporated
into Europe and there must be
redistribution of wealth.
And so it's coming down down down.
The recent surveys don't ask where you
live. They say, "How many rooms have you
got? How many people live there? How
many this? How many that?" When did they
do that? And in what country?
In communism. And what happened if your
house was bigger than your need? The one
who had the need got it. But who has to
pay for it? You, because you own it.
It's even worse now than in communism,
right? So they came to our country. Now
you have to register in each individual
location and you may not vote outside
your location so they have your location
attached to your name. And then they
came to my house and they said they want
to know what is my religion. I said I'm
a Christian. They said which
denomination are you? I says it's none
of your business. They said it is my
business. Which denomination are you? I
said it's none of your business. How
many rooms have you got? I said enough.
We want to know exactly how many rooms
you have. I said, "I have enough." But
we want to know exactly. It's got
nothing to do with you. Why do you want
to know exactly? I could have another
one next week or I could put a wall in.
I could have two, right? So, none of
your business. You get into big trouble
if you answer questions like that. Not
supposed to do that. Therefore, they
must be made available to all men
everything necessary for leading a life
truly human.
Did you know that living a life truly
human
is the Catholic acronym for salvation?
And I will prove this to you in a future
lecture where they say to be saved
means to live a life truly human. That
means the kingdom of God for Catholicism
is the kingdom of Catholicism ruling the
world on this earth and giving everyone
the capacity to live a life truly human.
That means enough to take care of your
basic needs and nothing else. Do you
like the new world order? Do you like
it? Do you know what they the Bible
calls him? the man of sin.
Now, there's another word for the
redistribution of wealth, and I've given
it to you already. What is it? It's
called
theft.
That's right. The Bible says, "Thou
shalt not steal." That means, "Thou
shalt not take from one who has and give
it to someone else." That's called
theft. That's breaking the commandments
of God. Is that correct? Yes. We will
see that this system of human rights
breaks every single commandment of God
as we go along. When God distributed
land to Israel, how was it distributed?
As an eternal inheritance. It was your
land.
Ahab wanted Nabot's vineyard.
And Neabbod said to him, "I will not sin
against the Lord my God because this
land has been given to me as an eternal
inheritance and to my children.
God gives each one a piece that is his.
They take it and distribute it according
to need, but you pay the bill."
Fascinating. The complex circumstance of
our day makes it necessary for public
authority to intervene more often in
social, economic, and cultural matters.
The second Vatican council, that's what
it said. So they're going to intervene
at every level of your life.
Loron gobbachoff paps gobbachoff praises
the pope and he says the pope is right
in his demand for a new world order. In
the San Francisco chronicle already said
pope calls for a new world order. Albert
Einstein says mankind's desire for peace
can be realized only by the creation of
a world government. With all my heart, I
believe that the world's present system
of sovereign nations can only lead to
barbarism, war, and inhumanity, and that
only law can assure progress towards a
civilized peaceful humanity.
Interesting statement. Albert Einstein
what did uh he also state? He says there
is no salvation for civilization or even
the human race other than to creation of
a world government. That was Albert
Einstein.
What did Utant, former secretary general
of the United Nations say? He said,
"World Federalists hold before us the
vision of a unified mankind living in
peace under a just world order. The
heart of their program, a world under
law, is realistic
and attainable." What did Nortima Elder
say? World peace is impossible without
world government. Winston Churchill.
These are big names. I'm not not talking
about small fry. The creation of an
authorative world order is the ultimate
aim towards which we must strive.
Charles de Gaul. Nations must unite in a
world government or
perish. How do you do that?
How about creating so much conflict
that everybody will be willing to give
up their sovereignty?
Do you know what? In South Africa, I
give these lectures
to the public.
The people are in despair.
They are being robbed, driven off their
land. They are being murdered. Our
houses look like prisons.
We cannot go to sleep without locking
everything. In my very own little block,
we've had murder after murder after
murder and robberies, aggravating
robberies, and nothing seems to happen.
Police don't even care. They don't even
come out because there is so much
turmoil all over the place that it
cannot they cannot even cope with it.
So, who cares about your little problem
that you've just lost everything? Take
it to the insurance and see if you can
get it back. Irrespective of the pain,
they come in, they move in, they take
all your private papers, they burn them.
You have no record of your life.
Everything's gone. They sell the
furniture they don't want, and the rest
they keep for themselves and say, "Get
lost. It's now time for redistribution."
You had land before, now it's my land.
That's how it goes. This is the new
world order. Welcome to the new world
order.
Bertrand Russell. The only possibilities
are now world government or death. The
humanist manifesto too urges us to move
towards the building of a world
community. Robert Miller, former
assistant secretary general of the
United Nations, said, "We must move as
quickly as possible to a one world
government, a one world religion under a
one world leader." I wonder who that is
going to be.
These are big, big names that I'm
putting on the screen. These on
speculators here and there. I'm often
accused for speculating. Well, the
biggest speculators are these people
themselves.
And what about this man?
We saw how peace and unity was to come
about.
>> It was great.
>> A great feeling of excitement of peace.
>> Of love. Peace. Love and unity.
>> Unity.
>> Yes.
>> Nations will come
and worship you
and worship you.
above all the heart
and all the world
Gathering
singer.
Pope calls for a new world order. CNN,
Thursday, January 1, 2004.
He made his whole new year speech
revolve around the new world order. I
want to tell you today that the new
world order is intended
not just to unite the nations which God
had separated. That's one aspect. but to
eradicate
Protestantism
of the face of the earth and
particularly
that form of Protestantism
which refuses to bow to the papal
Caesar. that form of Protestantism will
have to go and we will see that under
the circumstances that will be created,
these conditions are all in place right
now. It is all there and I will put it
on the screen for you so don't miss the
next lectures. Now we're getting into
hot territory. I'll put the quotes on
the screen where they will tell you who
the problem children are going to be.
And don't think it's Islam, it's someone
else. Don't miss the next exciting
episodes. But before I go, I would like
to remind you that Jesus said that this
was going to happen. And if I know and
if I understand with my whole mind and
with my whole heart that Satan because
the dragon gave him his power and great
authority is setting up his kingdom here
upon this earth.
Then instead of becoming disillusioned,
frightened, hysterical,
I know that the time must be very short.
Isn't that right? And I know that the
Lord must be coming very soon. So, as
far as I'm concerned, I have distanced
myself from my property. If I literally
had to come home next week and find my
wife somewhere in another little room
and my house occupied by whomever, then
I will say, "Tough cheese. It's going to
blow up anyway. Who cares? It's going to
be destroyed when the Lord comes by the
brightness of his coming. Why not take
it now? Have fun while you can. And I'll
move on somewhere else. I don't mind
building a treehouse for a little while.
That should be okay. If they take my
cars, well, that's okay, too. We'll get
another one. If we can't afford another
one, we'll we'll walk. Who cares? I
really don't care anymore. But people
who are losing things
become desperate. And what do they do?
They commit suicide. By the thousands,
people are committing suicide. If they
understand this message and they
understand where we are going, would
they then commit suicide? No. They
gather hope. They say, "Wow, so we're
part of a big excite exciting end game."
And this is exactly what is happening.
People are getting hope and they're
giving their lives to the Lord Jesus
Christ. And they are saying, "Lord, save
me not only from my sin, but save me
from this world. I am longing for your
kingdom. Do you know what the government
policy is in the kingdom of God? I've
already told you. Everyone in the
kingdom of God gets a dwelling place in
the city built by who?
>> By God and it has your name on it. Did
you know that you have a city dwelling?
In the new world, what happens? God
says, "No longer will they build houses
and others live in them." So what are
you going to do? They will build houses,
says the Bible, and they will plant
vineyards. And no longer will you plant
vine vineyards and others eat of them.
What does that mean? That means you will
have a country dwelling where you will
have a farm which God will bless. And
who does it belong to?
to you for how long?
>> Forever. Forever and ever and ever and
ever. That's God's policy. So, who cares
about what they're going to do? Who
cares? And I has not seen nor ear has
heard the wonders that God has prepared
for them that love him. That does not
just include the glory of seeing our
king in heaven. It includes everything
that goes into making life pleasant.
And the new kingdom is worthy of waiting
for. Really, I look forward to the new
kingdom of God. It'll be a great place.
And we will unfortunately see this world
go from bad to worse. And I don't want
to lie to you and say it's going to get
better. I'm going to tell you it's going
to get worse. very much worse. What
happened in the French Revolution is the
forerunner of what will happen in the
entire world. There will be anarchy like
you cannot believe. But if you are under
the protection of the most high,
nothing will happen to you. So why not
accept him? Why not say, "Lord Jesus,
I want you to be my personal savior."
>> Why not say, "Lord, clean up my life.
Let's walk together because your
government is the only one worth having.
And imagine looking in his face and
saying, "Wow, this is my God. I've
waited for him. He will save me.
Heat.
Hey. Hey. Hey.
Heat. Heat.
Oh,
Heroes of Flight 93. The official
version is that this plane was heading,
let's say example, for the White House
or for the Capitol building, but that uh
some heroes on board overpowered the
pilot and then the plane crashed onto
the ground, killing all the occupants.
Very fascinating stuff. By the way, of
all the four airplanes involved, no
black box has been found. No black box.
They are designed to withstand such
crashes. There is not one that has res
has remained. Now, Shanksville, what
happened here? Now, this we don't have
in English. It's in German. So,
subtitles have been put underneath and
you can read it in English as you go
along. And we can see what happened
here. The people come and they now
interview the mayor of Shanksville who
was one of the first at the scene as to
what actually was present when they
arrived and you will find something very
interesting.
>> Well, yeah.
My brother-in-law
was standing Shanksville in the corner
of the streets
right there and they were the firstbody
and there's no airplane.
You lived here?
>> No. Where are
>> this? This is it.
I always
complete
airplane debris.
>> Nothing I could identify.
But this is what we saw.
That's an interesting story.
So, here you have an interview with the
eyewitnesses that come to the crash site
and there's no airplane, but there's a
hole in the ground and in the hole,
nothing. No airplane. No airplane
debris, nothing. just a hole in the
ground in which a whole Boeing
disappeared totally dissolving itself
with nothing to show.
Interestingly,
they have the bodies of every single one
that was on board, but there's no
airplane.
Now, that is weird. You must admit
that's kind of weird. And that is the
picture
of the the actual cloud that formed.
This photographer just happened to be
there when it happened. And that is the
cloud that forms when a bomb hits like
they used in Afghanistan.
And the question was asked, was it
perhaps a bomb and not an airplane at
all? And where is the airplane? We
wouldn't know. It's gone. Now, nowhere
in the history of the world has an
airplane like that just disappeared. I
mean, imagine when your shuttle exploded
up there. What a terrible disaster that
was. And that was like a nuclear
explosion in midair. They could almost
reconstruct that shuttle from all the
debris that they put together. Isn't
that correct? And here nothing. Nothing.
No airplane. It's gone. No airplane.
Very interesting. Let's go
and look at what happened at the
Pentagon. Amongst reports circulating is
the report that there was an explosion
in the Pentagon. Now according to this
an airplane flew into the Pentagon.
Let's have a look what was aired on
national television abroad. Question.
This collapsed.
We shown by Shanksville.
telephone.
Well, there you have it. That's the
second one. Here comes an airplane,
crashes into the Pentagon, goes through
a hole, leaves a hole 1.8 m wide. A
whole airplane leaves a hole 1.8 m wide.
The rest of it collapsed later inside
the building. No airplane debris. It's
completely dissolved, gone. But there
are clocks and there are telephones and
furniture. They seem to have survived.
nothing else, no engine block, no
nothing survive, no airplane.
Whereas if you go to the World Trade
Center where everybody saw the airplanes
fly in, what do you find there? This is
the situation
center.
There were no problem there. That was a
massive explosion. If anything should
have ripped those planes apart, it
should have been there. But there's lots
of debris of airplanes.
But at the Pentagon, nothing. Not a
thing. At Shanksville, nothing. No
airplane. Dissolved completely.
So no wonder this Frenchman over here
says disperses. It's the Pentagon.
The evil is it in the Pentagon? This is
the man who came up with some of this
theory. Who was it? What happened over
here? And was it perhaps totally
different to what people are saying?
These are pictures that were released.
Interesting that the date says September
12th. They say that it's because they
released it the next day. Here is the
sight of the plane when it is about to
crash. And then suddenly a black
picture, nothing. And then you have a
flame. But there's no airplane, nothing.
Now, when an airplane lands on an open
field at this low and it's struck right
at the bottom, then the landing gear
comes down automatically once the altter
reads that and there would be a line of
destruction in the lawn like you cannot
believe. But there's nothing just that
hole. And this is the cloud of flame
that one sees. And this tiny hole in the
building which then later collapsed. Any
debris that you see lying outside has
nothing to do with the Boeing. Has
nothing to do with an airplane. So
there's no debris from an airplane at
all. Gone.
The fact of the matter is that
immediately after these events, the
power was granted to act internationally
and you had massive legislation,
homeland response, all of these things
came in. Now, I'm not saying who it was.
I'm not saying what transpired. I'm just
giving you the facts as they were, and
you decide whether the official version
is okay with you.
Heat. Heat.
Hey.
Hey. Hey.
Heat. Heat.